I think this is one of the major
unknowns about Obama he in some ways has
to succeed within a very traditional
broadcast style of politics and
governance but there's also the outlines
of a new system and I think the new part
is coming from a fact that's actually
even bigger than Obama and our
preoccupations in electoral politics and
that's that the falling costs for people
with the same interest to share
information and collaborate and find
each other in the first place that is
what's changing the world the falling
costs for like-minded people to locate
each other share information do
something with it and then tell the rest
of the world and whether your campaign
recognizes it or not that is out there
and it's happening and so there's no
doubt that an American government
realizing this shift could operate in a
different way than our government does
now and there are people who want to
make that transition happen who want to
see the age not of Internet fundraising
and organizing a campaign over the web
but something much more profound which
would be government of the people by the
people and for the people in which the
people actually have the same
information available to them that the
government has and that kind of openness
that kind of transparency is certainly
going to change government eventually
but we really don't know if the election
of Obama would bring it on we didn't
really don't know at all if he would
govern any differently then Bill Clinton
or for that matter Joe
it's it's there as a kind of as a kind
of a undertone and as potential but the
rest remains to be seen and we have this
problem about talking about change when
it comes to technology and and these big
shifts is we ask you know whether it's
going to be one or the other we ask it
that if it's you know the internet is
taking over or really not much of a
factor at all
so we have to have some more complex
images here sort of like they're still
running the old stadium but they're
building the new one right or you know
right around it you know we we function
in both worlds at the same time the old
broadcasting system is still there for
much of the country and much of the
campaign is being run through it and
that underneath and around it there's
this new distributed system of sort of
many-to-many politics and media and it
the to interact with each other so I
think we're gonna continue to see that
you